hey do you want to get dinner tomorrow
night late you were going to stay late
well it's always for you it is isn't it
i'll have dinner with you though should
we yeah can you get me laid
i'm gay
[Applause]
actually i'm not you know they think
their friends give you pressure like
what are you going to get her yeah what
are you going to get her it's like i
don't know what is she going to get me
yeah huh
she's going to get me a flat screen oh
it's ridiculous the pandering you have
to do
no it's like am i in some third world
country i got to buy off the corrupt
dictator here like
it was very intimidating i only took
comfort in knowing that i'm playing this
version of superman of batman excuse me
is the um that's right it's
understandable i know i got a little
flustered there
what is my
hidden talent
no
buddha don't you dare don't
you dare okay
only pg rated answers name three things
that get you in trouble with your spouse
the internet
uh i i don't take care of myself that's
the problem really yeah no but you know
what i started to have i had um
yesterday surgery yeah no hey let me
finish my own sentences
and i am you're gay no i'm not gay
and you're going to spain no i'm not
going to spain you're gay you're going
to spain yeah it's a great place for gay
people i mean you don't have to go far
on the the interweb to find uh quite
extreme reactions to that scene but you
know shirt on here's what somebody tell
michael b jordan that my ovaries are
ready to be michael c jordan
anybody
[Music]
i broke my back what do you mean by that
your back is broken everybody says who
does he think he is i just told you who
i thought i was a god
i just told you that's who i think i am
hey everyone
i'm jill biden's husband
at night i be flying
i believe i can fly
i am a unicorn
you are a unicorn we are unicorns
is ryan reynolds related to ryan gosling
canada had sex with america and then
they made the two of them and they're
twins
and both of them tried to eat each other
in the womb but they didn't they
survived and because of the trauma they
both became actors and that's why the
two of them are actors and who they are
i can't feel my life i would never fire
any person in this room
except the car oh no
except for car reason ben he's old he's
useless
he's just not good to me
so carl sorry girl you got to go
for real you got to got them
and the number one eminem piece of
advice for the kids
don't waste your time watching this show
what is the dumbest thing you've ever
done while you were drunk
i thought of what i just thought of one
i don't know if it's dumbest um i i um
i knew you'd have a good answer for them
i um i weed on my girlfriend once
[Music]
if i was a boxer i would
bounce those things like sugar ray
leonard
i personally don't you know want to talk
about your ass but you're the one who
who wrote the song superb ass
what
you wrote a song called superb ass oh my
god my song is called super bass
super
super ass super bass oh my god
juicy and big
you have fantastic loaves thank you
told you conan
mine gets bigger if you just keep
all right kanye give us three things
that are hairy balls balls balls
muchisimos projects
okay you have a lot of projects around
that you could have chosen you picked
this one why ah
good you got it you got it okay uh
battle
um
[Laughter]
[Music]
people see it as taboo still um so i
it's why it's a ballot measure bill
because no politician even if they
thought it was a good idea
oh my god
is it odd that i'm really proud of that
i know
there's another one too that i saw that
was equally
they're in the bathtub but look
that looks like i'm giving birth to
myself
it does
someone um i haven't seen this gentleman
ever so if you're watching please listen
up um he
does a lowest lane impression whenever
i'm walking my dog in the park
and he screams at the top of his voice
shouting help me save me superman save
me
here's ryan reynolds oh
like he's canadian look you punch you
punch a couple hundred orphans and
suddenly you're mean i don't this is
what i don't understand when i the
reason i the way that i met simon was
they asked me to be a guest judge focus
conan
to be um
[Applause]
[Applause]
now uh who are you wearing i've got to
ask and get it out of the way
it's been way too long looking for the
one seeking through the night but
[Music]
an actor in a supporting role in any
motion picture
ben affleck
being aflac my fault
sorry about that ben
ben affleck
koran
no karen hines
belfast work with me now
and the winner uh the grammy goes to
natalia laforcay
[Music]
dude you oh i will look oh sorry i will
accept on behalf of her if i butchered
her name i'm sorry
all right hey how many uh feminists are
like going nuts why is this this white
male doing all this latino stuff uh and
the grammy goes to grupo
[Music]
kanye you're back after six years are
you happy to be back and performing
tonight much anticipated performance
with paul mccartney and rihanna i'm just
extremely happy can you tell by my face
your favorite dish
my favorite dish
i like mugs because they're
very comfortable in your hand and they
hold hot things that you don't have to
touch
so um you know coffee
or hot tea one last question uh i don't
i hate to stir it up but afro jack has
been talking [ __ ] about you anything you
want to say
who
afrojack
who
that's what i thought thank you thank
you eminem
hi
i'm vero de milo and thanks for tuning
in you know before i learned how to
exercise properly i was a poor excuse
for a woman
just look at those unsightly lumps of
lard protruding from my sternum
i was so weak and frail back then
i couldn't even tear a telephone book in
half
but i made that change and you can too
so let's get busy burning off those
fathers and bazoom
girls are you ready
all righty
let's start with a stretch
and
where did you go to school the
everglades i'm sorry i'm
for every new thing you teach us
you open the world to us like a stubborn
coconut
playing a demigod informing your what
your preparation for superman
um well i'm gonna say theseus isn't a
demigod
that's what he says on wikipedia yeah
wikipedia
using wikipedia is your source of
information
how do you feel about conan for real
connor is cool nicole he's a cool cool
cool white boy his jeans be tight though
these dreams do be tight
i mean damn look like conan back pockets
touching right now ain't never seen
[Applause]